you're live on youtube
thank you very much then good afternoon
to everyone
watching on youtube and good afternoon
to all the counselors and the committee
members attending
the external overview and scrutiny
committee
of this afternoon uh we are meeting now
um
the second time since uh covert has
taken its course
and uh we are now beginning to get
together and go forward from there
um what we're going to do is first of
all go through our agenda which i hope
you've been able to see
and pick up from the turrets website and
we're going to begin
on the agenda with apologies for absence
so that we can confirm who is here and
who's not of the committee
so can we have any apologies for absence
please
yeah we have apologies for mr topham
so we have um i haven't noticed
councillor ford
who's coach the ford president
no no no he's not chad could we just do
a road call for the um
the committee clerk please so we know
exactly who is here
ready are you okay with that chair are
you happy with us doing well
thank you
ford not president at the moment
councillor harding
here councillor hawkins
i'm here council langford
councillor leather
here councillor mackenzie
not here yet thank you councillor newton
yeah and councillor pennington
i am here thank you
can i just update you chair that
councillor ford is on the telephone at
the moment and we're just giving him the
code to get in so we're expecting to
join the meeting very soon
okay thank you very much indeed for that
information we are definitely core it
and thank you for other counselors for
attending and watching the meeting and
look forward to any contributions you
have um and we
also welcome any members of the public
watching this meeting this afternoon
we go to agenda item number two which is
the minutes the confirmation
of the minutes from on pages three to
ten
uh of your reports
and i'll take them for accuracy first of
all so
if we can go through out at the bottom
of the page number three
we start with page number three many
hands going up
page four
page five
page six
page seven
page eight page
nine and page ten
no hand scene oh well come to the
thanks jay just to move those minutes
okay secondary please yeah
any second there yes i'm happy to second
that
newton thank you can we take your vote
for
uh uh the uh
minutes of the meeting of the uh 22nd of
july so
being tested vote please mary angela
cottle honking
hawkins oh
pennington or
thank you committee unanimous chair
thank you
uh any matters of rising anybody want to
pick up with the from those minutes
that won't come up later in the meeting
any hands please
councillor cotter hunkins got a hand up
chair going to connor honking please
um i was just wondering obviously it's
great news about appledore shipyard but
if we've got any more um
updates on like orders coming through or
anything like that sean is there any
information
no nothing that i can pass on chair i
mean we've had
a few rumors but nothing i'd really want
to say in an open forum
and um because i can't substantiate that
uh the the the one thing you can say is
that we're trying to
uh now make contact with the new owners
of the site
and then we can try and network them
with the
the different marine networks that are
in place around them
so that they can have the best
opportunity to get as much benefit as
possible from those
thank you very much indeed any other
matters arising
chair can i just say we we've got
somebody in the waiting room i'm not
sure who it is it's a strange name so
i'll just if it's okay with you i'll
just let them in
just to see if who they are thank you
okay thank you are you okay with that
yeah
this is a it's uh adrian avery the an
officer that's fine chair
okay thank you very much in that for for
that
okay see is that we're all happy from
any matters that you wish to raise we
further then go on to
agenda item number three which is the
action list on the page
11.
[Applause]
great we come to the action list
and we go first of all to minute 25
and i can can i ask janet please just to
uh update us on the list
of organizations to be invited under the
forward plan items
um to be referred back to the 4th of
march meeting
4th of march next year or last year
janet
um we can make it next year if you like
yeah apologies for that it was
and i was updating that on the basis of
the discussion we had at the last
meeting
um around the revised forward plan so
there's still uh some information i need
to provide to that but it will be
for the for the next meeting and before
next march i promise
right thank you very much indeed and
minute
57 which is regarding the play strategy
um i think the question was answered on
page four of the the minutes um
when uh the planning economy manager
sean curran explained the answer are you
happy with that answer shirley
or do you want sean to say something
further on it
no no that's fine um it's just
interesting to know that
that it would be actually quite
interesting to know who the
representative is but
um that's being very specific um but no
that does answer the query thank you
okay i noticed that we do have for the
14th of october westwood housing on the
forward plan
as a question that we can begin to put
forward at that point
so that completes the action list
yeah just to let you know councillor
ford has now joined the meeting
welcome councillor ford thank you for
attending
we come to the uh agenda item number
four
public participation i've received no
notification of
the uh anybody wishing to speak is there
anybody
in line there john no chair no
no nobody's registered nobody's
registered okay
thank you we come then to agenda item
number five declarations of interest
uh you know the procedure and uh we wait
to see
as was really basically uh one item on
the agenda this afternoon
um so as the agenda item comes forward
then
if you have an interest please declare
it at that point
agenda item number six agreement of
agenda items part
one and two i have nothing under part
two so that uh
does not apply uh agenda item number
seven urgent matters brought forward
with the permission of the chair
um i have one thing um that i would like
to do i would like to
send a letter of thanks to virginia
pearson um
for her presentation on the 19th of
august about the the
local area management plan for
coronavirus
i was very impressed by it i think five
members of our committee actually
attended that zoo meeting um and i would
just like to
with the permission of the committee to
send a letter of thanks
for that presentation to keep us
informed um
with what's happening and i would hope
the committee would agree that we could
just
note a letter of thanks from this
committee which in one sense is
very much the work of external ons
working with health
and county council providers and i was
very very impressed with the
presentation
from virginia pearson um would you agree
it's committee please
to um send the letter of thanks thanks
for the letter
well that was doc the doctor gave us
that presentation
from the county council yes and
it was a presentation i think that quite
a lot of
people other than this overview and
scrutiny committee membership took part
in
i listened to it but i don't think
we need to send a letter it was just a
case of that was information from the
county council for us
okay well i mean it was it was a good
presentation but i don't think we need
send a letter about it yeah well
okay um is there any other views
yeah i'd separate
i'd second your proposal chancellor
pennington
well i'll make it a proposal then then
we'll have a vote on it quickly
um crystal langford
yeah i would just the same as as cheryl
i'd be quite happy to send a letter
okay um we got a proposal in a second
there
uh thank you very much indeed uh can we
take a vote please mary
yes chair counselor
cancel a ford
let's just be civil
sorry councillor harding four thank you
councillor hawkins that's four
ah
chair i'm not even sure we're supposed
to be voting on this it's not an agenda
item
okay i'm abstaining from it anyway
okay councillor newton
uh i have to abstain because i wasn't
present at the briefing
thank you and councillor pennington i'm
for
um i the vote is just to make sure that
we had a consensus of a meeting and it
was
under my permission my right is a chair
to bring matters forward
and it was something that was happening
and i think we needed to recognize it so
uh
um that was given the circumstances of
zoom
it's the only way to make sure that i
listen to the circumstances and the
feeling from
all the members of the committee under
uh number seven
um is there any urgent matters that any
of the committee feel they would like to
bring forward that we ought to be aware
of
and it's with my permission i offer this
uh situation
i s any hands
i see no hands yes
i have one you have one simon i can't
see your hand
unfortunately but are we are we doing um
that type of hand that's the blue hand i
think yeah i see a blue hand in front of
me no
okay simon briefly just just for
um information um
but i'm very happy to to to tell people
that
uh i i have um i have questioned with
the chair of cnr
um the fact that they are taking one of
our
cultural providers in isolation
at the next cnr meeting rather than
looking at
cultural provision throughout the
district as a whole
and it just seemed rather illogical to
me
that we were looking at um uh
one particular organization uh luxury
serving one particular area um when
we know because full council has been
made aware of it
that there are um other providers who
are also
uh seeking um varying levels of
support um and so i have purely
questioned the fact that it seemed a bit
strange to be taking one provider in
isolation
when surely we should be looking at the
function or the delivery of the function
district-wide um so
i say that just in case anybody hears it
on the
on the grapevine thank you okay thank
you very much for your comment
uh if you know that mary please uh for
force
uh recording the event that took place
uh uh i take it it's coming before next
monday
cnr committee is the bert art gallery if
i remember the agenda
um remember your rights as collins as a
committee if you wish to
to challenge any decision and we will
wait for the forward plan to discuss
if you wish to the wider cultural
activity of torridge
okay we go forward to agenda item number
two
chair you have some hands raised
i just put them in order here please
yeah go to the ford
hello chair okay yes go to the board
yeah um i don't know whether it's
appropriate but
it's something that is obviously uh very
current
especially with the bankrolling holiday
just um
been in gone i have had a letter today
from stagecoach about the parking at
apple door
because i did seen um the solicitor
uh our chief exec for one of a better
name and sean currently will know
that i have brought up obviously a jet
skis and i'm not very happy with peter
christie
counselor christie's article in the
northern journal
this is quite important i've actually
had a letter or email today
without any prompting from stagecoach
that they approached this council 18
months ago
about the difficulty of turning buses
which provide transport it's under the
terminal which you've got nothing at
bank end by the way
i am trying to do the right thing here
uh and the closing sentence which i will
fall off
is accident waiting to to happen uh
culture council six weeks ago i'm very
sorry
um it might be the previous
administration i'm not
interested in whose administration it
was but the previous one this one
that's got me sorted down there it is
dangerous it's over the density is
beyond belief
and when i see in a column that oh but
if the counselors won't agree
for jet skis to go to biddeford when
that when that slipway is still
zoned is launching the paragraph i'm
generally worried
and blood will not be on my hands but it
will not be on the rest of you if
something's not sort of
thank you thank you ford um can i ask
some guidance who is responsible for
buses and stage coaches and etc please
from our officers
you muted sean can you help me sean you
meet it
i thought i'd done muted myself sorry
about that um yeah
so we're we obviously responsible for
management at the car park church fields
car park
and within churchfield car park there
are some uh
bus waiting spaces and a bus turning
area
um each year for since i've been
involved with the car parks
there have been some issues at some
point in the summer
with uh bus turning quite often the
issues have been
with inappropriate driving by the bus
drivers if i'm honest too fast
um or something like in the car park but
you know we resolved those and there's
never any
big problem i'd be interested if uh
councillor ford could send me the
the messages received so that if it is
an issue in the car park obviously
that's for us to manage
um the slipway that cancer ford refers
to
is off of churchfield's car park and is
ours
um there are there definitely been more
use of that slipway this year than
than other years uh i think people have
broken out of lockdown and
making the most of the great outdoors so
that i mean it's great in one way
and in other ways is causing some issues
on the estuary
um we have had some
some local management issues down there
we used to have a slipway warden but i
think i've
i've previously reported that we don't
have that post anymore because we were
advised
uh that we needed to think very
carefully about what responsibility we
were taking for
the management of jet skis and the like
on the estuary because we don't actually
have a legal obligation
to to look after that so why would we
assume one so that
i mean that's something for members to
debate what role we want in the
management of these
whether we want to encourage the use
try and manage the use ban them i mean
there's all this there's all sorts of
things that are possible
for us to consider um but again i guess
members need to debate it fully in time
okay calling the short-term ass
counselor forward to
liaise with you on this specific issues
a chair
chair can i just come back yeah please
um i am trying actually to still
be a positive here but i'm very sorry to
say
i will not put up with basically kicking
a can down the road and waffle
there's a serious issue down there and
i'll tell you straight
right i will be going to the press if
this don't get resolved next april
because this is actually done like
dangerous we haven't done forget
the you can't manage the the river
because we haven't got aurora mass so we
can't afford that
it's our car park our slipway our
enforcement engineers uh
civil enforcement people they ain't
doing their job
and i tell you what pontius pilate wash
my hands of it
you lot can have blood on your hands
thank you
sir ford yes i hear what you're saying
i've
had some comments about the busyness of
apador
in the last six weeks um i've been doing
there two or three times myself
uh we have no intention in this
committee of washing our hands of
anything and i did hear your words about
an accident waiting to happen in your
first comment
um but from the point of view this
afternoon's meeting
um i i we we can forward the situation
and ask you to develop the situation
with our officers
and report back to us but i'm not taking
the matter any further this afternoon
but i would not take the insinuation
that we as committee are washing our
hands of the situation
we want to see an action taken where
there is a risk
and then seeing a combination of the
situation and i hope that satisfies
so that we can move forward in this
situation
thank you sean did you want to comment
on anything else
uh no chair no i don't think so
it's um i suppose i would just speak in
defense of our civil enforcement
officers
who i believe are actually doing their
job and
they they they are trying their best we
only have four for the district so we
can't have
somebody within our current resources
standing permanently in
churchill's car park but they are doing
the best they can into to manage the
scenario
i thank you for your response thank you
council ford for bringing it forward to
us
and i will continue to watch it
alongside yourself
and uh and i i aware of your original
comment about an accident way to happen
because where there's anything turning
in a public car park
one is always aware there is a risk and
it's it's difficult
right we come forward now to agenda item
number eight
which is the torridge play and open uh
space strategy
sure i'm handing over to you it's uh to
lead us on and the presentation
of this uh strategy thank you chair well
obviously this is a long awaited uh
draft strategy uh it's something we've
been talking about for
for a long time now if my recollection
is right we started
uh thinking about the need for a play
strategy when
when members became much more interested
in the provision of play because of its
importance to our communities
and obviously as you get more interested
and want to do more things we need to
then to direct
more budget more resource more activity
more time
towards the delivery of these services
so
in order to provide some justification
for that let's use my phone ringing in
the background but
providing justification for that we
thought
we needed to have perhaps some direction
to
how we are going to get involved so what
we did um and again i like i say my
apologies
has been going on for a long time
started last year to pull together a
document
that looked at what the council's role
and play might be in the future
and how we might direct our resources to
the best effect
so what you've got what's been sent over
the agenda is a
first draft of the document um we
thought it was important to get it to
you it's rough and ready it's uh we're
not pretending that this document is
is the finished article um
and so we wanted to get it to you in
this form
so that you can see that something has
been done some thought has gone into it
it does outline for you the the main
strategic directions that we're talking
about so
the recognition of the importance of
play about protecting and looking after
and maximizing access to our open spaces
about how we empower capacity build
within communities to take
management responsibility or even
ownership in some cases of some spaces
it talks about how we wouldn't normally
seek
to acquire place spaces unless there are
exceptional circumstances
um and it those sorts of things it talks
about equality of provision actually as
well what's really important
point is that we should think about uh
people with disabilities and how they
might access
play facilities so so it's just really
to get your feedback now
i think we need to we need to polish
this document we now have adrian avery
who's joined the call today you might
some of you might have met adrian
adrian's picked up on this piece of work
um and this isn't his
all his work he's topped and tailed it a
little bit from what was provided from
us
by our consultants and and previous
um community engagement officer and um
he can work on this so it's really we
want to hear your thoughts
on on where the document is at the
moment uh what you like what you don't
like
and then we can go away and try and
improve it
to reflect what you want it to achieve
thank you
thank you chair uh thank you sean um
adrian avery
have i met adrian avery before adrian
joined us he's
uh so he's our community engagement
officer he sits in with uh chris fuller
and hey mission our economic development
team
i think adrian's been with us about a
month or maybe a little bit longer but
not not very long
and is a passionate torrington man who's
uh
very well connected in community circle
so he seems to take him to the job like
a doctor water and if you haven't met
him
it would be great to introduce you to is
he is he
on the on the system john today i think
i think he was the guy with the funny
name that john let in
john um well adrian can you come and
just say a few words to us so we can um
see you see your face and uh i apologize
i should have
but i have not been in the riverbank
house for the last month so um i've not
had a chance to meet you
if you can say hello to us adrian and
the committee
my counselor chairman can you see me i
can't
all i can see is yourself with there if
you can see me with me
uh i'm looking
yeah good afternoon thanks for letting
me in on the call-ups this is
my first one some uh some learning like
i said like uh sean said they're only
uh five or six weeks into the role very
much enjoying it
it's a great place to be so far and so
i'm very much looking forward to um
getting my teeth into things like this
so um
thank you for letting me in and i look
forward to working with you all in the
future
okay so um welcome and uh thank you very
much for your work and contribution
to this document both the uh the uh
report and the document itself i'd take
it from that point of view
so um just refocus you on the
recommendations that we'll be looking at
at the end of our discussions
and are on page 15 is to consider the
draft play and open spaces strategy
and suggest any changes they might wish
to be considered
and secondly when content
approved that the strategy should
progress to community and resources
committee
for adoption okay so so
um when we've gone through the content
we can then
go forward to cnr um for them to adopt
the strategy from that point of view
if you wish to you could add further
recommendations at the end of the day
um so i threw it open to the committee
and um
welcome some comments please um uh of
what we have before
us um councilor langford
thank you um right um i've
been through the document and i've
scribbled a few things down
um i wasn't quite sure how we were going
to go through it if we were going to go
through it page by page or whatever so
i've now very hastily
tried to bring my thoughts together so
i've got quite a few points here
do stop me if i'm getting boring or if
i'll try and be quick
but maybe let's start things off um now
then
sure casual lankford yeah you raised a
very good point there
um and i think that the the where we
will begin is
we will go through the document page by
page
um and you each of us will have our
contributions to make i'll try and make
some contribution
notes as i go along and then we will
look at the the overall global
presentation of the strategy as well so
so we'll look at what is present before
us and then we look at the wider picture
as well
from that point of view so fire away
please go to the lighting fruit
okay okay i wasn't quite sure
what to expect from the document um
and i suppose um as a as a strategy
i i was expecting something more
specific i think um so my
my first reaction was that it was a bit
over general and vague but then
um maybe i misunderstood the point of it
um so um uh
i i kind of was waiting for something
more specific
for various reasons there's been various
parts i've been concerned about so i was
kind of waiting for
more specific things and i feel as if
those specific things are still missing
but if you are looking for a strategy
that you can build
on then this does the job um there's a
few things that
that i feel very strongly about i really
really agree with even though the
council does not
have to um look after parks
i really think it's really important for
for play etc um and i do think the
council should set aside
a substantial amount of money and be
prepared to maintain them where they're
responsible for something they should
maintain it and if there's a problem it
should be
put right as soon as possible um some
other things that i've
uh thought about are that where
parks are taken over um by estates or
whatever
i think we have to think very carefully
about how that's done whether that
should be in the strategy or not i don't
know
but there's a specific one down at
halsey wood just down the road from me
where a very small player has been put
in right by the main road
and it's not it's never used and it's
not visible from the houses in housing
wood so it's a total
waste of time as far as i'm concerned
with that and the other thing is about
in green
when um a housing agency takes like like
westwood housing
um they took that play area over
but there was no commitment in their
agreement with the council that they
should maintain the play area
um so they don't have to maintain it as
a play area but
if they build on it they've got to
provide another play area somewhere else
and i just think that's too vague and
not specific enough and when we are
making these agreements we should be
very clear about what we want
in terms of um provision it worries me
about the
um the pressure on our leisure
facilities at the moment
the fact that they're not open at the
moment and therefore it's even more
important that parks
should be available because they you
know it's the leisure facilities that
possibly you could argue are the ones
that
less affluent people in our community
access rather than private gyms
so it's so important that parks should
be available i also think in the
documents it makes reference to um
how important the parts are for our
children it does talk about open spaces
for visitors but i think the parks are
really important for visitors as well
so often i hear uh visitors to the area
down at the park
um particularly biddeford saying what a
wonderful facility is and they hope it's
maintained
um in terms of suggesting that other
bodies may take responsibility for parks
in their area i
suppose like parish councils um i'm just
not sure
how that will be decided and you have to
be very very clear that
um if that is decided to be the best
option
that it is going to be done properly and
it's going to be maintained
um and i'm sure some other things will
come to me but i have a question about i
think it's the phrase a play
champion exactly what a play champion
is what that means um and one thing very
specifically about victoria
park in the last other scrutiny
uh meeting victoria park was uh well
knowing their um
a business that strategic plan victoria
park on the capital projects victoria
park specifically mentioned
and um obviously because of covid at the
moment it's just been maintained rather
than any big
um changes being made with the equipment
um
but i did i did ask at that meeting
was um were we waiting for this for this
strategy to decide what was going to
happen with victoria park
or were there delays with replacing
equipment to do with covid or whatever
um and so i was expecting something
maybe a bit more about
about specific parks in this i suppose
an overarching strategy
um i'm sure i've got some other things
but i'll leave it there
and see what i can do thank you okay
uh thank you for that uh play champion
interesting comment yes
um come to the leather
thank you chair well i agree with
councillor langford in what she said
initially that
this so-called place strategy documents
very thin gruel i think it's pathetic
really
on the front it says play an open space
strategy
there's nothing in here about open
spaces most of it's waffle if you look
at
what's listed in the index at the start
it's just quoting this
source that source there's nothing in
here
it's very poor we've waited months and
months for this
and what i'm amazed at is back in
november last year tivoli were given
a contract to produce a play strategy
for torrey's district council and there
are five
points listed in that contract
and i'll read them out because it's it's
important that members know exactly what
they were supposed to
have come up with the first thing was
review and update the current tdc play
area condition survey
to reflect the change in status from
september 2019
taking into account any further losses
and the new equipment being installed in
apple dora torrington and biddeford
secondly produce an assessment of all
other play areas in the district
provided or maintained by other
organizations
for example local housing associations
town councils or management companies
set up
on completion of speculative housing
developments
a large part of this works already been
completed by the tdc leisure team
but this will need pulling together into
a composite
schedule of all sites three
produce a compilation of all new stroke
future play areas or funding streams
for off-site play areas associated with
current and known planning applications
for new residential development this
information is currently being
compiled by the tdc planning team
but the data will need to be collated in
a way that will enable this
to provide the complete picture of
emerging play provisions
on funding available across the district
four produce a schedule of green spaces
will also need to be compiled to come
complement the overall data available
for the study
this should include areas of public open
space
that although may not have any actual
play equipment installed
will still represent an area for outdoor
play ball games etc
and finally at five on completion of the
above
the record information and data
available should then be used to develop
a concise
there's the word that matters concise
map and strategy
report to inform the council and
planning team
of the likely need for particular play
provision in certain areas
or an option to only target investment
into key sites
that are considered a district-wide play
destination
for example victoria park which is
shameful
the state that play equipment in
victoria parks in
so you know you can tell i'm spitting
feathers at this
i think it's a disgrace torridge for
many years have let down
the have been very very lacks in the
provision of play
in torridge district and it's something
that that really has
irritated me for many years but when we
were
holding on and holding on and this
tivoli had been given a contract
i'd like to know how much they've been
paid for what they've not done
and they've not come up with anything
and we've got this pathetic
well i don't it's not a play strategy
documented to always
i i you know we've been spending
apparently 82 thousand pounds of years
on maintenance
the last five years averaging eight to
two thousand pounds a year
what's that been spent on all i can see
torrid you've ever done
is take broken down equipment away and
never replaced it
i'll leave it at that for now chair
while i calm down well thank you thank
you counselor leather
okay i see no further hands up at the
present moment
so um we're all silenced by the report
there's quite an interesting
perhaps sean will answer what i've just
read what's tivoli been doing all right
i'm coming to short coaster newton has
just put his hand up
cozy newton please thank you thank you
chap
i think um
just pulling back out a little bit from
where
councillor langford was understandably
wanting to look at at
detail and just looking at the overall
the overarching principles of what this
strategy
is going to do um
first of all i'd say of course you know
as we all know this is discretionary
and in the new financial landscape the
bar is set even higher for justification
for
the spend of taxpayer money that doesn't
mean we're not going to spend it but i'm
just saying that
the bar is even higher because there's
less money to be
to be had and i think that
first of all the the strategy needs to
perhaps
identify the overall laydown of
play and open space of all natures
that's free access play and open space
so it it seems at the moment to be
rather focused on
what torridge has traditionally provided
well
actually we need to be we can only
afford
to look to fill the gaps so we should be
looking
uh first of all to see what's out there
as a whole
um for instance i looking at open spaces
um
when it immediately thinks of the
numerous devon
wildlife trust um reserves
in our region and they all need to be
identified
and and any any other um open spatial
leisure provision which can be accessed
free of charge
needs to needs to be recorded accurately
because then we can see where the gaps
are
and it may be that some areas don't need
a lot others need more
um out in the sticks in the villages etc
the the local play areas is
very much responsibility for the local
parish councils
and i mean one of my parishes has
recently renewed it
it's its play play area um and
has funded that uh with a small grant
from torridge but
largely they get on with it do it
themselves and it strikes me
that in our towns especially where the
scale is much bigger
and they have their own tax raising
power within reason through the precept
that the towns should be
um heavily involved in
the funding of their own
uh play and open space area first of all
that
makes it a much more direct form of
taxation
um and secondly um
there seems to be a bit of a um
a game here of sloping shoulders and
putting it all onto district
um when actually this is a very very
local
uh and community resource that we're
looking at
um the last thing
actually council langford mentioned was
she was commenting on
the precise location of a particular
play park within a private housing
development
or a housing association development but
of course the location presumably of
of all play areas is governed by the
planning
side so therefore that's actually a
planning issue rather than
um an issue for this paper i just make
that as an aside
um but yes i just think that we need to
you know look very carefully we cannot
do everything for everybody we couldn't
before we can do even less now
and therefore it needs to be very
carefully targeted
where there is there there are gaps and
also we need to look very carefully
at how much of a contribution the
larger um tax or
income generators in the area like the
town that the towns
are doing because i said a lot of the
rural parishes are getting on and doing
it themselves
um thank you thank you
we look forward to cursor harding yeah
um
thank you chair i'd just like to uh
second what simon just said i mean in
our
um the sticks as they call it in our
villages
and likes of bradley and heartland that
they do look after their own play
equipment
yes they may source grants but they do
get on and
sort it out and yeah i think the towns
seem to be lacking in that um and and i
know they've got more but like it like
simon just said this precept is bigger
and uh
you know so there seems to be uh well
we're not going to bother we'll let the
the torridge do it but we have to do it
ourselves um
and uh yeah going back to the this uh
strategy
it just seems to be lacking specifics
and uh
you know that one of my um great uh
plans i would like to be involved in is
that get the the um
cycleway up and going and um
uh to westward oh and uh you know
there's no
um kind of strategy for how this could
be
done or whatever so you know i was a
little bit disappointed uh but it does
you know it covers everything but it's
uh it's covered
quite loosely thank you thank you
coaster horrorland council leather
thanks jay just to come back and answer
councillor newton and councillor harding
on what towns are doing
i can tell you northern town council are
doing a downside more than torres
actually
we've taken over we we run anchor park
in
apple door and we've re-equipped that
and done a lot of work down there
we've taken lord's meadow over from
torridge and have done a lot of work on
the children's play area that has spent
a lot of money there
we've taken ridgeway drive over in
westwood hall which torrid's just
stripped out of all its equipment
and left as a vacant space and it's now
classed as the most excellent play area
in the district
we've taken on apple tree close on
hanson park in biddeford
because turridge couldn't agree with the
developer about
a commuted sum to to look after that
little player so we're doing a great
deal on northern town council
thank you jose newton
i would just like to say that uh i'm
delighted
to hear what council councillor leather
has just said
in my understanding that's exactly where
a town council should be
and getting on and doing it um and if
i i don't have detailed knowledge of his
his patch
but that sounds exactly what my my
understanding of where a town council
should be
right at the heart of the community
providing the community level
uh stuff so um no that's that that's
brilliant i'm not cr
i'm not being critical at all if if
there's that level of involvement
involved
well uh chair if i may as well just to
say yes of course we've taken westwood
hall park over
down at westwood with all the financial
commitment that that
that's going to cost northern payers so
torridge had let that run down
shamefully down there that was in ruin
the park
and we've taken that on so you know we
are doing it as a town council
right thank you coastal leather are we
going to coast the ford
uh thank you chair um largely i would
agree with what councillor
levers just said however
i don't think it is a good idea
to bang our chest here like the
big silver bag because what i'll say is
in the last couple of weeks
i've had to go down and cut oaklift
terrace because the graphics
grass was appalling i've cut a verge out
going towards
watertown garage for the overflow car
park before anybody goes on about
uh insurance i said i've got insurance
to do cutting grass actually
with uh a place up at brisbane street
sometimes it's
good actually not do a lot of talking
just get off your ass and actually do
something thank you thank you
councillor christie who is not a member
of the committee but isn't deserving
christie thank you um yeah i would just
like to
raise a few points so councillor leather
has pointed out how northern helped
uh here in biddeford um the biddeford
town when i became mayor the first thing
i did was
uh get biddeford town council we
promised 25 000 pounds
to provide play equipment within
biddeford
that was matched by the british trust
which i'm chairing off
so porridge you've got 50 000 pounds
from the town
and i would add the british trust is
just about to have its annual grants i
have a list in front of me
and quite a lot of money is leaving
biddeford
and going to the villages to help their
play area
which is quite often forgotten about
actually
one other thing i would say uh about the
um
the cycling track uh which is mentioned
uh there was a meeting only just
recently
a week or so ago about this
with a county councillor county council
representative because it'll have to be
down to the county to do
most of the work um it is progressing
and uh if councillor harding would like
to join that group i'm sure he'd be
welcome
um i do have one specific question which
i'll save till later thank you
thank you guys to christy i guess i have
no hands
raised uh my courage to hoarding
i just like come back chair um thank you
uh cancer christie i would love to
be involved with the uh cycle track so
uh yeah if you could follow me some
information uh and
um meetings that'll be great thank you
okay thank you for that and i would be
introduced to the media's works i take
it the cycle track is planning to go all
the way to western health through
aberchum
and i am ward member for abacham so i
should be interested in those meetings
etc etc
um if you can afford them i'd be
grateful
um just a couple of things on the the
strategy itself
um from point of view i was lead for
leisure culture during the uh previous
administration and we did a playing
pitch strategy
stone that you remember quite well i
suspect uh first of all i want the um
tribute to james gerudi who's no longer
with us but he did an awful lot of work
under that
and again sad that he's no longer with
with this council but i never thanked
him for all the work he did and i like
that recorded basically
the difference between these two
strategies the playing print strategy
and this one
the play and open space strategy is
first of all
the size of it i i can't believe how big
one was and how small
the other was um and as i pick up some
of the comments from other
uh committee members um it's the pulsity
of what's actually in here
there's a lot of gaps in here figures
don't add up and i look at the the um
the cost of uh on page
35 when you have your your graph there
um and you're stating that you at least
410k in investment maintenance cost each
year
when i went out at those five columns
they only come to 303 thousand so
it just looks like somebody's not gone
through to check the figures or the
figures do not
match up to what they're saying they're
providing
um and i also pick up the comment very
much about
we're looking very much internally in
what we have not so much about what is
outside but i do
accept that it's administered from that
point of view
um within our situation but we do
recognize there are other providers as
well within the area
but we don't seem to be tapping into
them quite so much
now there's a lot of comments there sean
i wonder if you can
make response to them or adrian can make
them
response to them um in response to what
our coaches have said to us this
afternoon
yeah that's that's fine chair i mean i i
i'll speak it wouldn't be fair to throw
adrian in the deep end like this he's
only been with us a few weeks so uh
so obviously i'll do i'll do my best
because there were quite a lot
like you know i in broad terms i i take
on board
the um the dissatisfaction of cancer the
leather and
you know i i can't uh sit here and say
that
there's any excuses it's taken a long
time to get
to this point um it is in no way a
completed document
much of the work that tivoli have
referenced
would never got completed and obviously
they haven't been paid for that because
it wasn't completed i don't know how
much they've been paid
that's something i'd need to look into
um what they have done and what isn't
appended and coming back to the sparsely
document
is we haven't appended the condition
survey that will take up many
pages we haven't appended the list of
other facilities that have been looked
into
that would take up many pages so by the
time you get to adding all the
appendices into this
it's going to be a much bigger document
as was the playing pitch strategy
the playing strategy if you recall
wasn't simply
a a document that that outlined what we
were going to do or what a role was
it actually gave all the background
information um
if we go to uh councillor langford's
comments
about it not being specific enough um
fair enough i think perhaps somewhere in
this document we perhaps need to give
some specific examples
of some of the things that we think we
could do
we should be doing it's very difficult
for us in writing a strategy that
basically
sets out the intent of the council at a
strategic level
to be included in what i would consider
to be low-level business plan actions
because those discussions are yet to be
had what we need to do is adopt a
position in a strategic position and
from that
we can then talk to you about what we uh
propose for the capital programme or
what we propose for our
um revenue budgets in terms of
staff capacity to enable these sorts of
things those discussions have
been had because we haven't set the
strategic intent yet so
the business plans will have the detail
but i do take the point that there's
probably some specifics missing
from the document and we can look to
introduce some of that i thought it's an
interesting point
to make and something we can build on um
around if we transfer out pieces of land
we need
to assure that there's a commitment to
maintain those facilities i think that's
a
that's a good point um and then we
talked to um and council language would
ask a question about
whether how how things are transferred
well play areas are often transferred
by community asset transfer or or the
like
so um i wonder how we can do that that's
something we can pick up and investigate
a little bit further
um council newton's point about setting
the overarching ambition i'm glad that
that was picked up that there is an
overarching ambition in the document
like say i don't i don't propose it's
the finalized document and
i don't think that's been said um but
you can see the intent here the intent
is that we would
concentrate our efforts on what we
control
now and try and do that as best as
possible and then
that being the bigger play areas and
access to public open space and
and the countryside and then with the
smaller areas we'd work with our
communities now that might not be
through
the direct provision of equipment but it
might be through the provision of
assistance
from officers like adrian who can work
with the communities
to help them realize their own ambitions
so so i'm glad that that was
that was picked up and the role that
towns and villages have
in that um you know i i
i think those are the key messages that
i've got from
from what's been said and we can
certainly look to i was going to say
padded
but that's not what i mean i think
perhaps focus
um provide a bit more um
substance to the document it says it
says a lot of things
um but at the highest level it doesn't
translate to specific places but then
that's
i always think that that's actually
something like my job i take take a
document like this
and use it as a hook to
leave a money in to develop partnerships
to do things in specific places
and if i can find um that hook in a
document like this then it's fine
that this document starts to do that it
doesn't complete that job
and perhaps it needs to be a bit more
specific i sort of got that message loud
and clear
okay i've got counselor coddle honking
if it went for some time
uh character cuddle honking
thank you yeah i went through like
councillor langford and made a few notes
so should i i'll just
read out what i've written down so um
yeah i think it's great that we've
clearly made
play areas and open space provision a
priority
through this document because i think
previously it had been ignored and
equipment like councillor levers was
saying
was being removed and not replaced and
that was across the district i know that
was definitely happening in great
torrington
so at least having this document we've
clearly made
play provision a priority now um
i'm a little bit concerned where it says
about
um resources being strategically
targeted
and there's talk about being accessible
for all
um but if we're
strategic strategically targeting
maybe like the big play areas and i
wouldn't want to see the smaller play
areas being lost
as a result of that because that's not
making it accessible for everybody
and i get that we want to want equality
and providing
equipment for people with disabilities
but it's also about providing spaces for
people
who for example don't have access to a
car so you still want to have the
smaller play areas that everyone can
access
like they can walk down the road and get
to their play area i wouldn't want to
see those being lost
um i also forgot
i talked about engagement with the
parishes but i assume that this would
have been part of the
strategy already but obviously that
hasn't happened
very quickly yeah that has happened
there was some engagement with the
strategy
with the parishes so so when james was
with us
he wrote all the parishes and we have
see this is coming back this this isn't
the complete document you have in front
of you we have an analysis of what's
held
in each of the parishes and and their
conditioned assessments of those things
uh but that's not appended to this
because it doesn't it's not really
strategic information in terms of the
document
is just a list of what play areas are
more parishes but we've got that
okay it's just that that was written in
the conclusions about
having engagement with the parishes so i
read it as though that hadn't
taken place yet it needs to be updated
as does the condition survey so that
so we've got them in rough form we
probably before we adopt a document
based on that evidence should up just
quickly look them over to make sure it's
still accurate
cheryl i know you're there yeah conor
honkin
um interesting i read on page 18 uh
which is inside the uh
second page of the strategy you've made
a comment there
and i wonder when you made that comment
um
and go back to page 14 of the report
i think it was written by sean um
lead member reviews not yet salt and i
just wondered
when you actually sent your your reviews
in because they said this was prepared
in february 2020
and not published until it says
um published uh september 2020 well we
were only september the second today i
think it is
so so you obviously have this at some
point in the past
no what may no i
well page 18 it
clarify says statement from cheryl so i
didn't actually write that
oh you didn't actually write there so
chad just to clarify that's a suggested
statement
we haven't saw any lead member comments
on this because what we would do is we
were using this community committee if
you like
as a consultation forum once we've got
to a document that you're ready to go
forward to community and resources
i would hope that it would go with uh
councillor carl hunking's endorsement as
the lead member at that point
so there's been no lead member
consultation on this yeah
they have seen it the same as everybody
else
do you see the same as i'm just a little
concerned okay
um that when this goes into the public
domain that we are attributed comments
we haven't actually said
and uh um i think is it
a draft at the moment yeah it's a draft
documentary
in any way yeah okay i appreciate
my understanding of what i've used as
draft might be slightly different so i i
revised that comment then in the light
of that situation um
can you speak up because your life would
come to leather
um can i just ask sean and cheryl
uh country color honking um how they see
what a play champion and how that would
fit in
with the with the council because i
think president langford raised the
issue of the play champion
quite early on in her fresh comments and
i i was quite shocked to read about the
play champion
and how you envisage that fitting within
the the structure of our council
uh no no great thought about how it sits
within the structure of the council
chair
i think the play champion is just with
we recognize that there are a few
members
who are absolutely passionate about the
importance of play
um you know so so i know councillor
cottle honking for one as the league
member of communities but also
has a passion for play council langford
has mentioned many times
so it's about it's really about
developing a role for a counselor
to be the person the go-to champion
for that for this subject really it it's
no more than that it's not an executive
role
it's it's it's simply a sort of you know
if you're a counselor with a passion for
something
would you be the play champion so it
would be one below a lead member role
effectively
and um but reporting back to to the lead
for culture and leisure um to see that
come through from that point of view
i'm guessing so chair there's been no
debate about how it sits like that
so we could make it what we you know we
didn't mean
exactly what how the leadership would
like it to be
okay i'm coming now to councillor
language first and councilor leather
next council langford thank you
um and thank you for addressing some of
the things i've raised
um just another couple of points um
agreeing with um
councillor coppell hunkin about where
it's where it does say
about um ensuring quality rather than
uh quantity and i do agree with her that
um we do need to make sure that that
everything is a good quality but that it
is accessible
so it's no good just having big central
parks that have great equipment
um we do need to make sure everyone can
get
to them and therefore as she says the
small parts are still important it's
working working all that out um
about the whole document i do like the
commitment
to play and open spaces in the document
and the fact that it is saying it is
important and it's important to the
council that is
as an overarching theme that comes out
so that's great
um it just and and i take the point by
other councils have raised about
the business with parish councils and
being responsible for their parts many
many many many years ago in another
lifetime in heartland i can remember one
of the hardest things i
ever did was chair a committee to raise
money to improve
heartland's park which was part of the
playing field
and that was horrendous job um we got
there in the end but i mean it was just
it was very very difficult to do and i
just um
admittedly that wasn't that wasn't the
responsibility at that time of the
council
but um i just want to make sure that
when we say
i mean sean's already mentioned it to
get it right if you are
um giving responsibility to other
agencies that they are supported so that
it doesn't become sort of passing the
buck
although i do completely understand that
torridge's money can't go on forever
replacing you know equipment etc
but um we need to make it work and the
final thing that i just wanted to ask
whether
sean can um address this
it has a couple of times it says that
the play area survey must be done and
the play area survey is urgent
has that been done or has that been
started yet
it's so so chair yes so that's a piece
of work that i've previously circulated
just needs updating so
um it's i think it was a back end of
last year
it's not it's not ridiculously out of
date but if we're going to use it as
part of this
document it should be uh looked at again
but
that that was circulated to a previous
committee i think
i can remember some of the members
taking away a copy of that so you've all
had that i think
just on that matter will that form part
of the interactive map
that we will all be able to go and have
a look at to see
where the play areas are um
i guess we could look at that chair i
mean that we have that map
for the build facilities and um playing
pitch
i i um we'd have to look at whether we
could just drop the play facilities into
that map
it wouldn't be impossible to do i don't
suppose
well you've got the appendices on page
39
yeah um and you you map the strategy now
i've tried to go on the on the google
earth thing there but i can't seem to to
um
connect to anything to to show me where
all the the
the areas are adrian might know a little
more
i don't know whether he knows if wants
to come in if you don't adrian don't
worry if you don't know
you're muted adrian
hey green you're muted
[Music]
i don't know okay well
certainly uh whether an interactive
because you're playing pitch strategy
one of the areas that it fell down on at
full council
i think that back in october 18 um
our off hell don't know but cause
controversy
was that some of the um i think it was
the swimming pools at the time
um weren't highlighted across the
district and and um
that caused some some quite interesting
comments from
certain members who felt that their
facilities
weren't getting the same publicity as
other facilities
and i think every member should check in
their area to make sure
um that they have listed any open space
and play whether it's
torridges or whether it's for use of the
wider community that was uh
a situation that to cover back thinking
of how the previous
play strategy had difficulties getting
through full
council so i'm going to go to council
leather now he's had his hand up for
some
while then again to counsel color
honking
thank you chair yeah well i've looked at
the uh
northern devon playing pitch strategy as
well 2017
to 2031 that was mentioned a little
while ago
and of course if we're talking about
play i think we should be
included in that all play provision
football pitches in the area cricket
pitches all that kind of thing
besides play areas for small children
and
you know young teenagers
and of course in that that document
there's an awful lot
this list has been required in courage
again not nothing of that has been
mentioned
in this dismal document we've got today
i've also got in front of me here the
torres district council
play area conditions survey of 2019
and we've got 36 total sites now
down from 42 few years ago
and nearly half of them are only
satisfactory or poor
there's only one in there that we we
provide that's excellent
that's that's condemnation enough for me
but i noticed with the cheek
at the start of this document this place
play uh conditioned one
they mention right at the start um
the one that i mentioned earlier on edge
ridgeway court in west middle
this play area ridgeway court was
previously the responsibility of
torridge
district council and is an excellent
example
of a good quality play area and at the
bottom the note says
ridgeway court is an excellent example
of a play area
it was handled over by torridge in
2016-17
we do not have any play areas which
match this standard
um they could have mentioned that
northern town council did it but of
course they didn't want to do that
because it was such an appalling site
when they handed it over to northern
but the only the only excellent one is
um
in that list of her 36. okay
can you just pick
on that point about the measurement the
quality of the sites
and and how that's done through torridge
yeah so that's the document i was
referring to a minute ago chair when we
talk about the outstanding things that
we need to do to finish this
that's the document that was previously
surveyed um
sorry the survey that was previously
done and circulated
um that was done for us by tivoli so
when counselor leather refers to they
i'm assuming he means our
agents at the time um and and i guess
they probably wouldn't have known
if i'm honest that that we didn't hand
it over in that condition
it is fair to say that when uh before
northern took that on
it was an unattractive space and they've
made it an attractive one so
all all kudos to know them on that one
um i don't think anybody's trying to
claim any glory
how often do we we you've listed 36
sites in this document
yeah how often do we go and actually
make and check the safety of the each
playing area we have listed
so that's done that's done frequently
with uh under our grants maintenance
contract
but it's not recorded in this form so so
that's a function of our grounds
maintenance contract yeah
so safety and the public safety is
absolute paramount
absolutely yes yeah so what that that
comes back to
in it if you like the knee-jerk response
to austerity was just to turn off the
tap on many
many areas of discretionary spend the
most
simple way to make something safe is to
remove it
yeah and it's it's it's a cheap way of
solving a safety issue
um now what you know i i'm sensing from
you guys that you you
you don't like that as an approach so
what this document is suggesting is that
we concentrate our resources
on providing fewer things in a better
way
and and actually making sure that the
quality so that when next time we have a
an assessment of quality
as councilor leather refers to there we
have more excellence
across the the survey rather than than
many many
poor or average facilities you know so
that that's really what
what this document is trying to lead you
to is guiding people to
decent fewer decent torrid owned play
areas
and making accessible less
formal recreation spaces for play
okay thank you sean thank you conscious
honking i've been
on the hand up for some time um yeah
just a few more specifics on the um
document on page 24 it says what does
storage need to do
and it talks about provide the
opportunity for consultation with the
community
i'd specifically like that to include
schools
um because i think that the children
need to be included in the consultation
i spoke to adrian avery a few days ago
and we were talking about doing some
sort of a survey at great torrington
community school and i think that would
be something really good to do across
the district
yeah include that as a specific um and
it says
encourage community participation in
fundraising
and provide support where needed and i
think it's really important to encourage
the setting up of community groups to
enable more funding to be made available
so in great torington there's
four different community groups set up
well three specifically just for
individual play areas
that's kingsmead burwood and calf street
and they've successfully now pretty much
transformed each of those play areas
through their own fundraising efforts
i'd like to see that happen
in different parts of the district as
well um
thank you
sorry sir
oh it says the following projects in the
torch district have been provisioned
with the help of grant funding it's got
kingsmead
and birds and it's also got churchfields
appledore but i would like to find out
which grants those were because i
thought it was
somehow fully paid for by torridge
district council
miraculously with some funding that
appeared
so i wouldn't i'd like that taken off of
the help of grant funding as i don't
think that's that's true
um what else and it talks about capital
investment
and the 400 000 pounds i'd like to know
what the breakdown
is in terms of um investment from our
capital funds and investment from grants
and fundraising
as well okay thank you very much for the
comment
uh and christian newton
i'd just like to follow up on on um
what counselor leather and sean were
both just
saying i think what counselor leather
was was demonstrating
um in fact successful practice
uh of what happens when actually
these local community facilities are
taken
back into the ownership of the local
community that they apply to
and as a result you get a much better
quality level
of focus uh on on what the local
community wants
how it's going to be maintained and we
as a higher level um authority
uh assist perhaps with granting at with
grant money at times
but i i really start to think we're
looking at we're down to 36 sites it
says here well um
into large contracts covering a very
diverse area with
different requirements in every part of
the area you can't know two will be the
same
and divorced from the local communities
that they actually apply to
as well i think it's it's it's always
going to be a recipe for disaster and
i'd be looking at
trying to give back especially the more
localized ones
give these back to the ownership of
local parish and town councils
and then support those organizations
through a
grant process rather than trying to
um through a indirect process
and through contractors etc provider
what will always be probably a pretty
substandard service we'll always be
playing catch up
um let the people who who have a real
interest
in them let them actually
run the things and they'll do it better
than we do
thank you kevin newton before i come to
council hudson um
she got a hand up just follow on from
country newton's point about uh
local versus district um in the
appendices um
shown there's case studies for ashrini
parish council
and chumley playing fields is that
run by the local parish or is that run
by north devon district council do you
know
um
i've no idea how chumly's managed to
creep his way in there it must be just
an example of good practice again if
adrian knows more i don't i mean
obviously chummy is not in our district
ashrae is uh a great example of
how another small community group has
got up
and got on with it and we've helped them
to deliver something for themselves
ashrini in torridge yes it is it's mine
thank you and and and rather i'd just
like to correct
sean in saying rather than just another
local community group
sounding like it was a a band of
well-motivated volunteers
no it's a local elected parish council
they are the people who are put there to
do a job and
really they they and they're doing it
excellently yeah
um because they they are delivering to
their local electorate because that's
exactly what they put there to do
um and indeed if they didn't then
hopefully the electorate would throw
them out next time around
it's coast saluting is is chumbly in
your parish is that across the border in
north devon
no it's across in in in north dam uh
it's it's not
the middle not in our district not in
our district okay so we're there
in is in our district i've been
interested to see a local one that's in
the torrid
area um being put in there to see how
that was working there so i'm grateful
for that information
we go to treasurer hobson hello thank
you
for letting me speak i've listened very
intently to everything that's been said
um and i have just a few points to make
with regard to perhaps the necessity of
rationalizing our portfolio
and as councillor newton and councillor
harding have suggested and
councillor leather has demonstrated how
successful it can be
when assets are taken on up by
town and parish councils i'd like to see
something in the strategy
that actually firms up these potential
arrangements and opportunities
because um i can't let today
go past without stating that uh
northern town council for the privilege
of taking over westwood home park
after a long and hard fought battle
to prevent housing being built on it
have had to pay torres district
council 100 000 pounds for the privilege
of it
now some might argue that it was an
asset that was
because it's torridges uh that the
torridge district council needed to
benefit from it i'm not arguing about
what's done
i am saying to you going forward we need
to clearly think out
how we arrange community asset transfers
if it's going to benefit communities and
working with torridge to facilitate
access to grants to help them
that this is firmed up in this strategy
because without that um you know
we were in a position at northern that
we could borrow that money
to make that purchase we haven't started
yet
there's going to be a lot of investment
from us
we will benefit from section 106 funding
for recreation in westwood ho but still
the people who contribute to the precept
that we have will be paying for that
so um yes i take my hat off to people
who've done it
but i think you need to be very clear
about
how you how you take this going forward
because it is as somebody's pointed out
a challenge i think um shirley said
about uh heartland and getting it all
together
it is a long and
you need a very dedicated community to
actually achieve these things
and what they need as much help as they
can get so thank you for that
thank you very much indeed coaster
hotson for that
okay as i have no further hands raised
and we've had quite a fair bit of
discussion
uh uh sorry one hand further raised from
chris leather
close to the leather well just to
mention chair in the uh
play area condition survey the list
lists um 18 as being good and they're
colored green in here
the ones that are considered to be good
looking through it
tp 35 golf links road westwood whole
is mentioned as being um
is listed as being good but actually
it's poor
so i think somebody ought to look
through this again and just reassess
some of these
and it's i think local knowledge will be
important at the
more detailed stage of looking at uh
this is obviously a recent survey it's
2019 so
it's not as if things have changed that
dramatically since then
but um i hear what councillor hudson
says and i agree absolutely that
you know what a battle it was for us to
be able to take over the park at
westwood or to save it
and it shouldn't have been like that but
that's how it was in its history now i
know
and we're gonna okay
i would still like to know
what tivoli have been paid by torres
district council
okay i'm going to come to him yeah i'm
going to come to some recommendations
chris and we may want to put one of
those as
recommendations that we want answers to
okay so we'll come back on that one
again in a minute
can you hear me yeah yeah
well all i'm saying chris we'll come may
come back to that one's the
recommendation a minute i want to come
to
to to to drill closer christie
thank you yes sir i'd like to make one
point and ask one question
um one of my points is i i we're talking
about open spaces and parks
and yeah i see nothing in here about um
perhaps taking the maintenance of our
parks back in-house because
here in biddeford uh privatization
of that um work which was fostered on us
by the government
uh purely for ideological reasons has
led to basically
i get so many complaints about victoria
park about
how it looks today and how it used to
look and yet there's nothing in there
about that i wonder if we shouldn't look
at it because it's yet another example
of privatization not working
uh i can't think of any privatization
that's worked actually but
um i have a specific question um about
morton park
in biddeford this is a new estate where
we were
tories was due to get a sort of multiple
use games area
about two years ago when the estate
was actually completed and yet nothing
has happened
up there is completely overgrown it's
not in my ward but i still get lots of
complaints about it
um can any ot one of the officers tell
me what's actually happening up there
are we taking over that as a play area
are they going to
make it a play area can we
coaster christie can we leave that one
for the this afternoon please because
that's
drilling down into to actually the
management of the areas i think we want
to leave that to the ward members
um whoever is in morton park area to
raise that for the time being and i
want to focus really on the strategy
here rather than drill down just at the
present moment we will make a note of it
um the ward members can follow that one
through and get an answer back to you
if that's possible please chair i i
could very quickly because it does
relate actually to the to the discussion
you have in here
this no no we don't intend to take that
in-house that's entirely the way that
that's meant to come forward this
section
is under section 106 and it's to be run
by
the uh management company of the
developer
um and and as i'm as far as i'm aware
the some play equipment
has been installed up there the area has
been tidied up because
i drove past there last week and it
seemed quite popular
so i think quite a lot of the work maybe
not all of the work has been done
but uh i can give you a more detailed
update but that that is a model of how
we would proceed with
um play in in in that is provided by
a large development we wouldn't take it
ourselves we would expect the
development the developer to come up
with a management solution for that
thank you for your response sean uh okay
christopher
actually i hawkins just going to say i
would like like an answer to
counselor chris christie's question but
um uh
sean kenney has just given it so that's
good um
one of the concerns that i have we we've
got to park
in stoopy road um but obviously it's not
owned by the council it's um
westwood housing
is there any way of getting some more
information about
how we could either work with them or
you know we
almost like take over the park so we can
improve it
because okay can we have a question
in terms of a strategy for torridge okay
um and we'll come to our recommendations
now because we can all drive down into
our individual routes and
and we we are 380 square kilometers of a
district and i don't know what's
happening that's raining obviously
because i've just asked a question i
should have known the answer to
um and and then that's right he does you
know may not
know the intricacies as partially would
at the top of buddyford
um but what we need to do is get some
clear
guidance about how we actually put a
higher level strategy in place
and yeah we need answers to the
questions coastal hawkins and coaster
christie's asking
um um but we we within the time we have
here
need to get some responses now and some
guidance to how we want to respond and
send this back to our officers
to forward this document and i don't
want to get dragged into
too low level of a situation about what
happens in this road or western hill or
moreton park or ashrini it
is making sure that we have some
guidance
about how we work within the council for
the parks we
own but also all the other providers and
also there's a wider aspect here
um is all the wonderful areas that we
have around here the coast path
the talker trails uh touring components
uh and there's another issue coming up
which i don't think
anybody's touched on is that there's
tremendous changes coming
with the funding of the agricultural
sector
and there's terms about the public good
and and one of the themes that are
coming out from that it seems to me
is more access and use of the
countryside because one thing has been
absolutely apparent through the pandemic
is is that people have been very much
cooped up in the towns
and we have a lot of countryside and
even the barrels got closed down there
for goodness sake for so many weeks
um because of the pandemic and people
just did have nowhere to go to and no
access
to breathe basically within our towns um
i know what that breathing is dangerous
on each other but we got 640 acres there
of the barrels and we weren't making the
best of it
and i just think with the changes coming
through agriculture and
other issues that may come through that
issue of what the public good is
in that funding are we looking at
looking at
other sources of income and that's i
think
one of the areas we've not picked up at
all in this one
no the seasonal hands i want to move
into a situation
where we actually draw some themes we
can send
uh from this committee back to our
office
to further this document and whether you
want this document to come back to
uh ons again before it goes to cnr
because there are a lot of gaps in it
and that would be one of the choices you
have to make so what i'm going to ask
you as a committee now to do is to think
is come up with some
pure uh clear recommendations
that will guide the strategy that we
will set for the future and i don't want
this to get into a
really localized argument but it is
about how the council
will work torres district council will
work with all our partner organizations
and this own resources for the best use
of our community so i
put it to you any recommendations uh
that you would like to come up to add
to this document check but
may i just make so we've we've received
from from you
some fairly clear messages i think many
if not all of the members of the
committee have had
a good say obviously read and understood
what the document's about where the gaps
are in it we've got quite a lot to work
on
um would it just be suffice for us to go
away
and amend the document and come back to
you with an amended document for your
consideration rather than going
through a number of different
recommendations
i is does any of our committee have a
burning recommendation they wish
that was put into our officers to make
sure the message is sent
can i ask coach carla honkin i was just
going to say that i agree with
what shawn said because we've already
given our sort of suggestions
as councillors of the committee i think
it would be good if
if they're happy with what we've sort of
highlighted and then come back and we
can look at
it again and then okay coachella newton
sorry sean no that's okay you'd speak to
cancer newton and i'll chip in
afterwards if you'd like to
coaster newton please yeah sean i'd have
thought that we are
definitely looking at this coming back
to this committee chair would you agree
um i think also yes with its clothes on
properly before it's
it's fit to go anywhere near cnr yeah
okay well would that provide us
current sorry casual leather thanks yeah
yeah i think that would be the best way
to go because
looking in this what we've got before us
this afternoon looking at the previous
place strategy which was
for the district between 2000 2007
and 2012. i mean eight years ago
if you looked on i'm looking on page 27
now
you look what was the themes were
identified as actions within that
document
you could almost put the same ones down
again now
and one thing i will mention is the
final bullet point
on page 27 develop formal planning
guidance for toys
to deliver play priorities that's not in
our local plan
on the current local plan it used to be
in the old plan
the leaps and the laps and all the play
areas
were specifically mentioned in our old
plan with what kind of equipment the
size of the areas
the muggers the size of the all that
used to be listed
and it's not any longer in the local
plan listed and
i raised this issue only and i'm not
speaking every term
on the uh um dad and hill site we had at
the last planning
meeting that got planning permission
outline plan
full planning permission the pathetic
play area they were thinking of putting
on there
was we've taken it out it was taken out
for them to come back with a proper
a proper area and a proper design scheme
on there
but we used to have that in the local
plan we used to have a list i've still
got the list of it here that used to be
requested whether it was a leap which is
a locally equipped area of player or a
lap
a local area or a mugger multi-use games
area all these were
listed depending and we should have that
in
in a play strategy or in our plan
preferably but we should have
a document that lists what we expect in
our planning process
to provide so can i ask you uh coach
leather and
um our planning manager sean um
would this document you finalize become
that supplementary planning document
that would be attached to the local plan
um now that we would use it would not be
no you would need to further yeah update
and change of the local plan
yeah so so this is a corporate document
that guides us in our in our sort of
corporate functions if you wanted to
create a submarine planning document
there's a wholly different process
a statutory prescribed process okay
um and this wouldn't be that the
personal leader you've identified
chair i wasn't going to suggest that at
all it's just that we do need somewhere
a list of what kind of equipment we do
expect on play
areas or playing pictures and while
we're making recommendations and i
accept this document should go away and
come back with
as councillor newton said it's clothes
on
um but we ought to roll into this as
well the north devon playing pitch
strategy because
for me that is important besides the
play areas we've talked about
you know torres needs at least six adult
pitches and
youth pitches mini pictures lots of
things in here
holes where there needs half size it's
all in this document
and that ought to be rolled in too it
should it shouldn't be just about the
play areas
the conditioned survey that i've got
here the players we need a complete
concise which is what italy was supposed
to be giving us
i'm sure that um picking up on the
consultation
that i think council hawking mentioned
uh mentioned in stuttley road
and west country housing at number two
when i read out the contract
and it says contract that tivoli were
given
it speaks about assess all other play
areas in the district provided
or maintained by other organizations for
example local housing associations
town and parish council so that's not
been done and yet they were given a
contract to do all that work
appreciate hear what you say um i just
saw i just want to
ask a further question regarding
aligning this to the playing pitch
strategy
that strategy is no fully in place isn't
it um
is it standalone it's a yes it's an
adopted document yes so
so i mean we're in danger of a bit of
mission creep here
in that we set out to do something for
play areas and we're now
we're almost right writing rewriting a
local plan as we're moving forward
you know i totally understand that
interrelationships between the different
issues and perhaps this strategy needs
to reference the playing footage
strategy
it can't rewrite the playing pitch
strategy that's a wholly bigger piece of
work
sean nobody wants to do that i'm not i'm
not suggesting that at all but
it says place in its open spaces get
mentioned in this document or should be
and there's no mention of open spaces no
that's fine we can reference that
that's no problem okay okay well it's
sorry can you call counselor cuddle
honking
i was just gonna say i don't want it to
lose focus on the play areas because i
think that it is
well we need to focus on the players
that are available
in the district and there's already a
strategy for the
playing pictures but obviously
referencing it would be good but i don't
want
it to turn into something that's going
to be like 500 pages long
nothing counselor newton and i'm going
to begin to close this down because i
think the
wish of the meeting is that um your
officers will go away and work on it
courtesy newton um you're almost a a
point of order in a way
um sean who is actually the author of
this
is it the consultants tivoli or
is it used for members um
so officers here in in in riverbank
house
technically who's authoring the actual
the actual um
thing on paper that we're looking at
it's a bit of a hybrid chair
so it's um uh there's been there was a
basic document that was provided by
tivoli um as i understand that our
property team had some input into that
and then adrian
has topped and tailed it a little bit
since then so it
it it's not solely tivoli document
following up on uh councillor leathers
very good point
about we don't seem to have much to show
for um um money that's been thrown at a
contractor to do a job
at the moment um in the future if we
continue to be
uh concerned are we are we able to
ask tivoli to um appear
before us and and um comment on their
work
uh i think through the chair we could
let me let me pick it up with adrian
redwood who was directly liaising with
tivoli and
much of what tivoli did as i understand
it would be the background work that you
can't see today
okay so so so so i i
obviously the document we've not got to
the point where there's a completed
document
um and much of that was because you know
we moved into the
covid scenario and nobody was there
working and we've just picked it up and
cracked on to be honest because
there's some urgency to get something
there so i i can't provide you a
definitive definitive answer as to
what tivoli did for their money um but
we
you know i'm sure adrian redwood who was
liaising with them would know much more
than i do
might might just might just sharpen
their focus a little bit
if they feel like liable to be um
asked to come in and justify what
they're what they've done for their
money in front of us
sean we we are at right to ask anybody
they are at right to refuse
um but we can ask the next time this
document comes before external
ons that they attend the meeting um
and if they refuse so be it but at least
we can extend that invitation
so that we can get the background
thinking to where they're coming from
basically so i i
certainly would echo um we can request
that they attend
czech
given the importance of of of this uh
strategy
um i think that we ought to at least
inquire into the situation about looking
at asking a representation of
of them to come i don't know if
anybody's against that
principle on the committee but i think
that seniors is coming back before us
and seeing
as they've done uh you know prepared
this uh a lot of this document
um there's nothing to ask uh what would
have cost us even if they
attend the committee
all gone quiet okay um well anyway i
think we can we can certainly make an
inquiry if
they would attend and i ask that that to
be recorded
because of the leather i agree with you
chair absolutely because it says a
contract has been let
to tivoli to produce a play strategy for
torres district council
and then it goes on it says tivoli will
and those five points that i read out at
the start
they're all listed there and for my
money they haven't done it
well i don't want to get an issue about
the the the
the money is an issue on one point but
but it is the wider concept of
the thinking behind and and where
they're coming from as well yeah
and and they are external and uh we can
certainly invite them
um uh but i would check on what they're
gonna cost us uh
uh sure
maybe being a little facetious there but
don't be surprised
okay right then no then to move on i i
get the feeling from committee that we
you want to go forward
and and to get the further work done on
this document to bring back before
this committee again without necessarily
adding any specific recommendations
to uh to the recommendations
already there is anybody objecting to
that
to save going through a vote i don't see
any air hands going up
that's right okay so we look at the
recommendation
chair i would like us to know exactly
how much we paid tivoli to do this work
that they don't seem to have done
then i could i can do that for you yeah
i'll just pick it up as an action if
you'd rather not vote on that that's
fine i mean i could
we could just add that to the other
report next meeting
if that is an action anybody against
that please show
no okay we will have that as an action
so we go back to the recommendations on
the report on page 15
and uh consider the draft playing open
spaces strategies
yes any changes they might wish to be
considered
well we voiced several uh um uh
changes um and leave it with the
officers
and second when content approved that
the strategy should progress to
community resources
for uh adoption um so
that means that just under two to be
clear
the strategy will come back to external
on s before it goes to c and r again is
that correct sean
yeah yes sir if that's what you'd like
certainly anybody against
those uh two show
no no hands i don't see any hands
because of the leather well i'm not
voting
for either of those recommendations i i
i would recommend we've already said
this is what we want to do
bring this document back when it's
properly when it's been properly
completed
simply okay so if you want to wear it
that way i'm happy to wear it that way
so the document comes back to us again
so anybody against that recommendation
that comes back to this committee again
let's do it properly let's put the
recommendation clearly forward then
close to another propose your
recommendation
that this player it's called a plain
open space strategy
playing open space strategy
comes back to the ons committee when
it's been properly completed
and i would say well it was doing within
the next
before christmas i'd like to see it
no reason okay
uh secondary please yes i'm happy to
second now i think it needs to be
uh chris i think it needs to be
described as a draft strategy
it will still be draft then it will yeah
yeah but i'm very happy to second that
do we have a proposer secondary can we
take a vote plea
any other propositions any other
amendments
no no hands going up so therefore we
take a vote please mary
and still a cottalankin
council afford or council harding
or councillor hawkins
or councillor langford for
councillor leather or councillor newton
four pennington or
unanimous chap thank you chair
thank you um committee sorry
okay we now come to the forward plan
uh that's right pages 44
and 45.
okay now remind me sean
the 14th of october is uh westwood
housing
that's right
who is coming and what is happening uh i
don't know i need to ask mary what
invitations have been sent out chair
if any yet okay
and we yeah
mary
did you hear me chad sorry yes i can
hear you
that's how's
has no no no invitations gone at the
present moment
not yet no okay
so so can you remind me of what the
drive
towards the foundation of westwood
only was housing and not housing in
general
i have forgotten i have to be honest
no i can't recall chairman he obviously
came up in our was when we had that
uh the last meeting and there was you
know the big
discussion around the fall um no then
yeah yeah it did crop up at the last one
sean's right when
we we discussed about the forthcoming
play strategy
there was a lot of mention and it's been
mentioned again
this afternoon that westwood housing
they're just letting a lot of their
play sites they're clearing them i mean
the one up at um uncle valley road
there's been emptied of play equipment
and nothing and we felt we ought to get
them before us and ask them
you know and this links in as opposed to
what we've been talking about today
that these outside providers should be
involved in the play strategy for the
area and certainly where they've taken
over
player areas on the housing estate they
were gifted by
orange years ago that it's not good
enough in my view that they're allowed
just to strip them there
when they quit obsolete and leave the
area
denuded if what was a good facility for
children
really one of the main reasons to get
westwood
yeah and the other issue cropped up i
think it was
councillor langford surely mentioned
about
representation on their board and we've
dealt with the representation
issue uh on the board
um they're looking for that together um
uh is it
uh sean is it possible to do the rehash
of the uh and uh bring back
this uh strategy for the 14th of october
as we have westwood housing coming
uh chair i dash it very much given the
scope of what you've asked us to look at
today i prefer to
aim for the november meeting if that's
possible
well that's a joint meeting with north
devon district council so our community
safety partnership
yeah um and that's gonna be quite
difficult to bring that together
and our play strategy will then go into
uh cycle six on the 20th of january
unless you want to have an extraordinary
meeting i guess
well i'm quite happy are you as a
committee happy to
have an extraordinary meeting um to
discuss this
matter sometime between late november
and early december
is that a timetable possible sean
is back it's better it's better for us i
think given
that we've got to review all of these
things we've got to
you know discuss with other partners um
yeah i i
think we'd be rushing to do what you
want us to do
but in for the october meeting if i'm
honest
then then i feel that certainly can we
ask
you to look at a um for an extraordinary
meeting
early in december
and secondly would you want to bring
westwood housing in
as new invitations have gone out at the
same time to tie in the whole thing
together
i think the chair i think that the wet
the play issue is only one
part of the discussion you might want to
have with westwood
and so if you so if you're asking that
we're going to have tivoli
in to discuss um it might be better
to concentrate again i mean we've had a
good debate on this one today and i i
can't see it being any
shorter if tivoli at the next meeting uh
you know because he's probably a lot to
pick up on so
an extraordinary meeting to just
concentrate on this would probably be
fine wouldn't it
yeah okay yeah okay anybody against that
i'm sorry coaster hudson
just sorry just as an observation i
thought the idea of meeting with
westwood housing and correct me if i'm
wrong i think sean's alluded to it
it's a much wider ranging brief that
external scrutiny might want to be
looking at with regard to
westwood housing's development plans
in the area how those are progressing
we've got a scheme nearing completion
in biddeford um an
update on their sort of strategic plans
for the future
and also their measures that they're
taking to meet
climate change and reducing their carbon
footprint
um you know that it's a
a much far much more far-reaching
brief than i would have thought just you
know obviously play areas and how they
manage those is a
important part of the communities but
they are our major housing provider
and it's an opportunity for us to talk
with them
and understand the direction of travel
they are going in
thank you for your guidance uh deputy
leader thank you for that
uh coachella newton
just i was just trying to jump in
earlier that
as sean's alluded to that is absolutely
why we agreed
to um have westwood housing in
um and it's actually got slightly it's
got slightly hijacked in a way by the
by the the play area issues uh and it is
definitely at the time we agreed it's
just a much wider
asking them to come and report to us and
brief us
across the piece of their activity and
their future plans
and then we can link that with
the current shortfall in in achieving
our affordable housing targets etc etc
so when we look in the wider housing
piece
um that that fits in because we have
better
better things so i would support claire
there in saying that the westwood
housing
needs to sit on its own um and it it's
uh
it's uh a wider issue than just
just play areas that's just a very small
part
thank you yeah i hear what you're saying
coaching you thank you for that cursor
leather
yeah i agree with that that's i
absolutely agree with that
can i suggest that we have a
extraordinary ons
meeting to look at the play strategy
draft again then
early november early early november
sure is that possible we can do our best
for you
well um um i i want to see uh
you know the appendices filled up and
and then
something a little bit more concrete
that will be
i don't know i know how hard you're
working sean and you guys work hard
to beat them yeah to be fair chair is
it's not necessarily going to be me
who's right in this so
don't worry about me i'm i'm thinking if
you want to look at something week 9th
or 16th of november something around
that
time are you happy with that 16th of
november guys
yes yes yeah are nine days
eight years november will be on
wednesday
yeah that's fine we'll work towards that
yeah the wake up for the ones we didn't
do earlier in the year then so 18th for
the special meeting okay
these uh ordering will be a becoming a
bit of a habit you know
and uh they're growing growing like
like trees all over the place um which
um we have too many key new members
okay so westwood housing stays it is
anybody
against leaving and changing that no
other
anything to be added we take that as a
standalone for the
14th of october 6 pm
we're going to have the extraordinary on
the 18th of november time to be arranged
and tivoli to be invited to send a rep
the 25th of november is a joint meeting
with the community safety partnership
with north devon district
council and do you want to pencil in
anything
for january the 20th at 6 pm
as a committee any any burning issues
that we think the
council newton should we be um
starting to think um about i'm not quite
sure exactly i'd be guided on this as to
as to how we look at it
um whether we should be starting to look
at employment
prospects in in in the the district or
the region
um by into the new year
we should be getting some fairly clear
indicators
as to what impact or not
um the ending of the furlough scheme etc
is having
and um whether we whether we want to try
to
take stock of of um what the employment
situation is in in the area
um and i notice there under um
our prosperous and sustainable economy
employment is obviously listed as
a key thing okay any other
suggestions for the 20th
i see no hands go i have one
issue that's come up to me two or three
times now in the last few weeks
um is is people in rent arrears not
necessarily with westwood but in private
social landlords uh private rented
landlords
asts etc um i understand there
is is about 300 000 homes up and down
the country
in serious arrears and that probably
translates to over 350 in
torridge um i wondered if we could not
bring in
the cab here and and i gather they've
been looking at
employment issues as well sean um to do
an evening to explain the effects of
on the families on on the ending of uh
furlough and the kovic epidemic honor
economy
i i don't know if that match together
chair could i just just come in and and
just add something
um we're currently working with the cab
and encompass um we have the hardship
fund available
uh within torridge district council at
the moment
whether people have been affected
directly by covered
uh due to their hours being downed or
um the loss of their jobs we have the
assistance available
um so we're trying to get the message
out there
there to people at the moment um we've
had quite a low
uptake on on the grant applications
it was money that originally came free
from devon county council
and very much hoping that um the fund is
going to continue
past their withdrawal of the furlough
scheme in october
but that's something that's there and
we've got assistance from those agencies
with administering it so
if any members do have any people within
their constituencies
that are in financial distress
um due to uh coved um
please get in contact when we can put
for an application for them
okay so going back to purely on simon
country newton's um proposal about
employment
uh is there any other suggestions
so how would that be best addressed as a
meeting
if the meeting feels that is the highest
priority for the 20th
of january i'm looking at cycle six six
pm
so can i could we liaise between now and
then about who might be
good inventees to that i mean we have if
we have a theme for the meeting
which is about the economy and housing
related issues
um or at this point in the pandemic
response
uh yeah perhaps we can think about
whether there are you know outside of
the meeting who who might be best to
come along and talk to us about that
are you happy committee with that to
pencil that in for the 20th
anybody's show disagreement please raise
your hands
then i think we've mapped out our next
four meetings
it's the 14th of october six o'clock
westward
25 uh 18th of november time to be
arranged
extraordinary return of the plane open
space strategy
25th of november 2pm the community
safety partnership
joint with north devon district and
provisionally
looking at the economy and post covered
issues
facing our community here in torridge
that sums up the forward plan at the
present moment because of the leather
well well just to say that one for
january
um when we looked at
what we might want in our program we
we we like that format that i think you
sent around
where if it's something to be discussed
that we can do anything about fine but
if
it's something to be discussed we can't
do anything about or make
any meaningful recommendation why bother
looking at and i'm just
sure might be able to put something
together perhaps that would be
worthwhile but
you know you know i just don't know if
we're going to
be able to make any meaningful
recommendations from
we all know about the economy all know
about yeah
you know the the threat to jobs the
terrible threat
that this handed handling of this corvid
thing has caused
the crashing of our economy um but i
just wouldn't
we can we we might be able to discuss at
a meeting like that
and make any mean meaningful
contribution to that song
and sure well just just as a thought it
just sprung to mind i mean it
stacey mentions the hardship so perhaps
it's about hardship
and about how we how we might repurpose
some of the funds that we've got to
address hardship issues
how we might support our communities
with hardship issues
how how we might tailor some of our
services to
to pim to to address specific hardship
problems
that might be something for us to
consider on that but yeah
i i totally get councillor leather's
point you know whilst it might be very
interesting to have a broad brush
overview of everything what are we going
to do absolutely focus on hardship
okay okay sorry
can i just add just following on from
what sean's saying actually from a
district council point of view it's
really important
that um we get the message out there
that people come forward to
us because there is assistance that we
can provide
um in terms of the council tax support
the benefits regime
the housing options as well because of
course we want to intervene as soon as
possible
um because it has a knock-on effect on
the rest of our services so
we can put the help in place sooner
rather than later
we want to be getting that message out
to to people
please don't bury your head in the sand
come forward and talk to us
and see what assistance we can offer in
terms of
support benefits and the hardship fund
economic hardship chair that's fine sean
sean and stacey have a dead right
economic hardship and we can
i think many out there and probably lots
of new councillors
including myself too probably don't know
all the things that torridge are able to
offer
to families and people out there who are
suffering an awful hardship
so that would be well worth it into and
then we could make any recommendations
then
you know we may have in the in the
journal or something and
then then let's make the 20th of january
focus around
yes the economy and the hardship pull
school vid so that is uniquely
fitting to what we can offer and help in
the large area
if you're an agree to that please
yes
yeah so we we pencil in the 20th of
january
for for for for the economy and
torridge's
help that's available in the post
covered hopefully post covered
situation that after christmas we may
fortunately
be facing are you in agreement with that
we do that
yeah we're with us chair
yeah you get rid of that virus so you
know there's no post about it
it'll always be there always be there
okay
you get the drift we will put the
economy post
or in the effect in the light of the
cool wood virus and
the help that torrid has and that will
be the
the emphasis for this at the emphasis of
the 20th of january meeting
okay yeah thank you
then we come no further
the agenda is completed thank you all
for your attendances
the time is now 1602
and thank you all for attending this
afternoon thank you for your work sean
on the presentation
look forward to doing further with you